my parents were from different worlds
and now is a product of the love that
never should have been could unite our
worlds one day
a son of the land and a son of the Seas
my mother always knew you were special
you are part of something deeper
you are the bridge between land and sea
take your rightful place as king
[Music]
we're getting close now
oh yeah close to what dying a thirst
there's no way Atlantis with this far in
there check this place out
it's real
[Music]
nothing of course it's not working it's
been sitting here collecting dust since
before the Sahara was a desert before
the Sahara was a desert you do your best
thinking when you're not thinking at all
right now hold still hey what are you
doing
we need water you're the closest source
[Music]
sure I could've just peed on it
[Music]
in this Trident resides the power of
Atlantis
if you seek my power
journey beyond the edge of the world to
the hidden sea
in the real hands
it would bring destruction
but enhance the true heir
it would unite all our kingdoms above
and below
what we've written it down first I
memorized it didn't you
oh yeah what are you just say something
something Trident the Beast has awakened
the time has come
for Atlantis to rise again
the hell are you
[Music]
oh is awesome the war is coming to the
surface
you are not going to win this
billions will die unless you help us
[Music]
I'm no leader
not King
[Music]
thanks miss always had a king now I need
something more
but what could be greater than a king a
[Music]
hero
you
you